i think a lot of people are like you and
i just kind of coming around on the idea
that so much of uh frankly what goes on
in this country today
is total [ __ ]
hey i'm dave rubin and joining me on the
reuben report this week is the host of
outkick the coverage on fox sports radio
and the author
of republicans wear sneakers too and one
of the best guests we've ever had on
clay travis welcome back to the reuben
report i appreciate it it's been
we were just talking before we started
here i came in october of 2017. so it's
been
almost two years uh since we hung out
last time and i got great feedback when
i was hanging out with you last time i
appreciate
you're gonna come on my new podcast as
well uh during this same kind of time
frame and uh the world may have just
gone crazier
you know we were hoping that maybe the
world would go less crazy when we talked
back in october of 17
and it seems like things have just
continued to spin uh wildly that does
fit well with my notes because yes the
world has gotten crazier since then yeah
it's been about a year and a half
yeah that i've been waiting to say that
stupid breast joke yes done on twitter
about a thousand times yes
uh but the thing that kind of put you on
the map outside of the sports world yeah
let's just recap that that little
nonsense because it does kind of capture
yeah sort of everything related to the
media and outrage and all that you
dared to say that you like breasts
and and the first amendment and i'm
still banned by cnn like
you think about all the people that
they've had on who've done all the crazy
things that they've
shown yes like i mean all of michael
avenatti who's been on you know and that
was
you know he's on hundreds of times and
now he's you know under uh under siege
with all the different charges against
him
but yeah they banned me for that uh for
saying i
the only two things in the world that
you know i can believed in completely
the first amendment and boobs and uh
and look it was good for me the book uh
republicans by sneakers2 came out
and uh it did really well best seller um
and uh got a lot of attention back in
september i think the paperback's coming
out i know you're working on your own
book right now
uh but i think it golf it kind of
galvanized for many people
what i think typically happens which is
the absurdity of
false outrage and what is and what
cannot be said and what should and
shouldn't be said
i think a lot of people are like you and
i just kind of coming around on the idea
that so much of frankly what goes on in
this country today
is total [ __ ] it's just endless
nonsense
yes and i'm glad you said something
there about the
what's happened to you since then yeah
because i think a lot of people
that care about what you do that watch
this show that are paying attention to
the
culture war and all that they still fear
that the mob will destroy it
and what i've been trying to show people
just through my own life every week that
the new york times calls me all right or
just the next
right right right right i'm like you
know if you actually
take a breath and don't lose your [ __ ]
in the middle of it yes
not only will you survive you will most
likely thrive after and i think you're
an example of that i think so and and i
think you're right there is this rush to
apologize anytime someone criticizes you
even if you're sticking to things that
you have long said in your career
my radio show is thriving you know
nationwide we went over 300 affiliates
and one of the wild things i think that
would surprise people is
my show is dominating in a lot of
different markets right like
our ratings in los angeles are up
something like 400 percent in the past
couple of years right
uh our numbers in kansas city are up
insanely on the east coast we have done
insanely well in the south where i'm
from in nashville
we continue to do outstanding the
podcast numbers are
are booming uh i started a television
show daily on
fs1 called walk it in which is focused
on sports gambling but we have a lot of
fun on there
and and i've continued to be as
outspoken as i ever have
and what i have seen i don't know about
you but is
people get frustrated because they want
to take you down and
when you stick to what you believe in
the benefit is
a lot of people have your back yeah and
they may not have your back in the same
way
publicly that you can but i am a big and
have long been in law school i
i kind of have come to this as i've
gotten older a big believer in the
marketplace of ideas
and if we're artificially constraining
what people feel comfortable talking
about
i think it leads to a lot of the angst
that exists in our country today
and so particularly in the world of
sports there are so many guys
and girls out there who regularly slide
into my dms and say
i 100 agree with everything that you say
but
because of how i'm employed or who
employs me i don't feel comfortable
getting out on the battlefield like you
do but keep doing exactly what you're
doing
does that type of person though drive
you crazier than the person
that doesn't contact you that just
remains quiet because it's like
you know you're not jesus you're just
doing your thing right like i'm just a
guy doing my thing and then
when i get these messages from often
people that are more popular than yeah
yeah
yeah
yes then i am having more money than i
am and they're subtly like yeah keep
doing it it's like
well i'm doing what i think is right but
like you know you get in this too like
get some skin in the game it's an
interesting question
i i think what protected me uh early on
was
i started my own site out kick and
i'll kick the coverage initially just
writing now we do a lot of videos now
obviously it's a lot of audio as well in
fact we do more video and audio than we
do writing almost now
and once i started to produce revenue
and realize and i think you probably
have gotten there too
you can take a breath and be like okay
i'm never gonna go hungry right i think
anybody who tries to get into media and
especially early on
when i left the practice of law my first
question was oh my god is my family
going to starve to death
right am i going to have to abandon my
media career to go back to practicing
law at some point and it's hard to get
over that right because i still feel
worried sometimes that fear is always in
the back of your mind because we live in
this canceled culture
that somebody wants to believe they're
going to cancel you so
it's i guess i wish that there were more
people who wanted to speak out
but if you're employed solely by a major
corporation today
i totally understand the fear of i got
kids you know
i got a mortgage payment i got my kids
college funds that i'm worried about and
everything else
uh and frankly the way i think about it
too is that leaves me a huge
area to to own right where uh there are
a lot of people who may agree with me
which proves
you know the audience responds to it but
others are afraid to say what i'm saying
even if they agree with it
which to me you know from a pure
business perspective i'm like well
i'll just keep rolling right i mean what
do you think it is about some people
that are willing to kind of walk
into that thing yeah because people say
that to me all the time
they always say that i'm brave yeah i'm
always like
it's not something i think about i'm
just doing what i think is right that's
it
that's a great line because when i was a
kid growing up my favorite quote was
from davy crockett
and davy crockett's most famous quote uh
i think still
is although who knows uh be sure you're
right that's some news yeah yeah yeah
be sure you're right and then go ahead
and so
by the time i come out with an opinion i
have worked through
every permutation of that opinion you
know like if i give an opinion and
somebody immediately responds on twitter
well did you think about
x which always happens yeah and in fact
we do on the radio show sometimes
we'll do a segment where i will flip and
start arguing the other side
and i think that's the lawyer training
in me but by the time i go out with an
opinion
i'm not just shooting off at the lip
like i have kind of in my head
worked through every different angle of
an argument and once i'm convinced that
my opinion is right i'm comfortable
putting it out there now here's the
other thing
if you think i'm wrong it doesn't bother
me yeah right like i i i almost think
i remember when uh when there was the
argument over bush of igor
and the two sides of that argument i
think david boyce had uh
al gore and the other side i'm
forgetting the guy who the ted olson
i believe was the other side and they
argued as hard as they could in front of
the supreme court
and then i think they shook hands
afterwards and may have gone out for a
beer
because they knew that it wasn't then in
their hands the supreme court had the
decision to make each of them had made
the argument for their side
as good as they possibly can and that's
kind of the era that i wish we could go
back to where
we can disagree in the old school senate
but you could have a situation where
oren hatch
and uh and ted kennedy are really good
friends and
that's kind of what drove me crazy about
this whole joe biden flare-up right the
segregationist comment like
just because you work with someone
doesn't mean you agree with everything
that they've ever said
and this idea that you have to be a
constant war with someone
is just something that i repudiate and
reject is it even worse than that in
that it's really a war with the past
yeah so when they get up there and they
say well buy it and you talk to these
people because he's actually got a forty
record yeah doesn't mean he loved
everybody and we don't even have to get
into the minutia of what he said or with
the people's
chance he shook or any of that but it's
actually an erasure of the past
yeah so you don't just magically you
know go like that and hope oh okay
everything's great we're in 2019 we're
all evolved and perfect which is
so ridiculous yeah i always i always
like to say because i
you know i'm a big history guy right um
and uh
you know the confederate statue debate
and everything else we live in an
era where we believe that we are
everything that's perfect in the world
and i was having this conversation yeah
yeah yeah right they're all idiots how
do they ever make mistakes
but the reality is that 200 years from
now we are going to be
advocating and embracing even the most
awoke members of our society
for things that others will find later
to be abhorrent that's just how history
works right and
so i you know the idea that we've
reached the end of history
is kind of fascinating to me because i
think 200 years from now it might well
be and i'm just tossing one out then
anybody who eats meat
is an infidel right like the idea that
you could have ever eaten meat
will be crazy it might well happen right
and and so
are people 200 years from now going to
be like oh we got to tear down
this martin luther king statue because
he ate meat we got to tear down this
statue of john f kennedy because
can you believe he liked the steak
wasn't for gay marriage it's the first
time he ran for president
you're gonna tear that library down why
are we building it right now in 2008
obama's entire platform would be the
most moderate platform of any democrat
running for president right now and
people would say is this guy electable
um so uh yeah what does that tell you
about internet culture because
yeah it is exactly where we started here
which is you were on the show a year and
a half ago we were talking about this
you were right in the midst of your own
little
bob situation and it's like we've
thrived since then and many other people
have the institutions have continued to
crumble i mean we've watched the way
trusted mainstream media has crumbled
watch the way trust in
in sports media has jumbled while the
little guy now doing their own thing is
doing great
what but what does that tell you about
just the the speed that we're getting
the information at
and where people are going to trust
things we're in a disruptive cycle
i don't think there's any doubt at all
and what i say all the time is
the only thing i can do and i love what
you do about this as well
is try to be as honest as possible with
my audience right and so the things that
i often get attacked for by people who
don't like me and i'm sure you see this
all the time too you're like
i address that all the time right like
all the time yeah like
people yeah and so i think trying to be
as authentic as possible
is ultimately the connection and i think
large institutions do not
seem authentic because they got their
fingers up in the air and they're paying
attention to
the vagaries of day-to-day responses on
social media
i also think listening to social media
is insane right
i mean it's a tiny segment of the
population that's often very very active
and so we live in an age of abundant
criticism
but i don't think we live in an age of
abundant reflection
and i think reflection is more important
oftentimes than criticism is the problem
though that
social media is becoming our only way of
reflecting so yeah because the
institutions are crumbling
and we don't have these the nightly news
show or whatever that we can all
basically
trust that social media has become the
mirror
but now we're all coordinating off into
our own mirrors like it would be a good
example like um
nancy pelosi said this thing recently
about aoc and elan omar it's like yeah
she's like yeah they're big on twitter
but they only have four votes but then
they all go after her on twitter and
destroy her and then the media loves
that
the whole thing is so out of whack with
reality yeah
or it's the new reality which is just
out of whack with i think in general
there are a lot of people who aren't
very confident
and this is what i always talk about
from a perspective of
you know let's say my world of sports
media if you are an executive
and you have gotten to the point where
you are uh high up in making decisions
at a sports network let's say
i think the idea that you would make a
choice on who you think is good
based on your 30 40 50 years of
expertise rising up to that level
and then because when it goes out
publicly a bunch of people on twitter
say
i don't like that guy or whatever that
you would allow that to be a reflection
of the real world and there's a great
stat
that's out right now that i saw where
it's something like 20
of people are on twitter let's use as an
example and of that 20
80 of all tweets are sent by like 10
of the overall population right and we
know that twitter leans far left
we know that and i know you've been in
your own battles over this
the social media companies as if those
company that they don't lean far left
enough already they're also magnifying
those voices right that reflect the
culture
by which they wish were more popular and
so
you're allowing ultimately you know
something like two or three percent of
the population
that isn't at all reflective of the
universe to dictate decisions that you
make and
i'll give you an example and this is in
the book uh i remember talking with espn
execs
and they said uh twitter hates lou holtz
and chris berman
right old school guys at nba at
espn lou holtz former notre dame
football coach college football guy
chris berman
maybe the most iconic voice in espn
history right put espn on the mat
and they said if you read the mentions
reflecting what they say on social media
everybody hates them
but if we are out in public those guys
get swarmed with positivity such that we
have to have security to protect them
and the question was do we listen to
social media or do we listen to the real
world
and to me you got to listen to the real
world right because social media is is
not reflective of real life
it's funny because after this past year
where i was on tour with peterson and
yeah 100 plus stops around 15 countries
and i'd be looking at mentions all day
and you know actually 95
of them are positive yeah but you know
it's always that five percent and
you know if five percent is several
hundred it can feel like a lot of bad
things but then i'd meet people on the
street and meet people all over the
world at airports and
you know restaurants and everyone's
great yeah everyone's
actually i was at ikea this weekend and
a guy kind of gave me side eye like
clearly didn't like me but i was like
that's as bad as it gets right but if
you're on social media all day you feel
like holy [ __ ] the world's coming to me
what i say is i've never had a person
say a bad word to me face to face
yeah i mean it's wild and in fact the
opposite of that
people will come up and you know ask for
a picture you know people say if i ever
see you i'm going to punch you right
like that's really confident
on social media right well they got to
punch you yeah yeah yeah exactly
and then what happens is they show up
and they want a picture
or it's even happened a couple times
like i'll block people right on social
media if they're
sending me obsessive you know 20 in a
row tweets or something because i do try
to go through and check every now and
then i don't spend as much time in it as
i used to
uh but when i do that i've had people
come up to me and be like man
you blocked me here's my twitter handle
i'm a big fan i'm sorry i was drunk that
night and i just got carried away can
you please
a couple times i mean and that's always
i think interesting because
um you know people are just not accurate
representations of themselves on social
media
yeah and uh and as someone who tries to
be as authentic and honest as i possibly
can
on a day-to-day basis uh because i think
you know one of my buddies said somehow
by being the most reasonable person in
sports you've made a career
and i think that just kind of speaks to
the polarity of the universe that we
live
in now that just being a guy who's
fairly middle of the road
seems radical i know the feeling brother
i know you and i have many of the same
similar uh
beliefs yeah and and kind of that's
funny though that so
so the two of us that come from wildly
different places yeah we're in different
spheres that these worlds have kind of
collided yes that that as we talked
about last time that sports has become
ridiculously political yes which in many
ways is why the institutions are
crumbling
uh and the fact that a guy like you who
mostly cares about sports
you end up talking about a whole bunch
of stuff that really is just
a sidebar but that is where the energy
is and saying something like hey
the u.s women are great but i kind of
wish megan rapino had shut up and just
gone to the white house
right or uh or you know the u.s women
deserve whatever money they can get in a
market-based economy but the men
produce a lot more revenue and people
are like oh my god how dare you say that
and i'm like this is the most rational
you know reasonable perspective or
you know uh the nba shouldn't ban the
word owners
because it's not racially insensitive
like the owners of the team are you on
those shows yeah
oh and theoretically although these
might be owned by fox uh
but uh they dress me when i'm out here
for television uh
but it's it's crazy like like
we're only going to define words by
thing and they replaced it with
governors
which doesn't even mean the same thing
and by the way if you're worried about
negative racial connotations
there's been a lot more racist governors
you know in the last 30 or 40 years
right than there have been
uh racist team owners so all right let's
do that
first i want to get back to some of the
gender stuff related to soccer and all
that
um but on the on the owner front yeah
the people that push these ideas so i
remember it was a couple weeks ago we
start hearing this they're not yeah yeah
they're not gonna call the owners owners
anymore
and you see it you see it starts
spreading across social media and people
start saying this is a good thing and
you know there's a connotation to
slavery and all right those things and
yet every part of you as a functioning
person knows this is nonsense they
own a team they own a business i own the
production company that produces this
[ __ ] you do not own the people who are
working on you like if they decide that
they don't want to work for you anymore
they can
leave and go work somewhere else i'm
renting them yes that's all right like
like you know it looks likely you know
it it's it's obvious
but what i think social justice has done
is it's created a situation
where even basic words now yes
have become triggers for some other
thing and it's like do these guys
actually think
they've done anything good that's that's
what i'm always trying to figure out
guys that believe this okay we're
calling them governors now
do they walk home and they go honey you
know you're not going to believe this i
i did something i i think it's all
motivated by fear so let's take a step
back adam silver is a white white guy
who runs the nba
right ultimately he's afraid if he
doesn't listen to
a few looney tune black players and make
this decision
that ultimately they could decide oh
wait adam silver's a white guy who runs
the nba
he's like a plantation master right like
that's the analogy that they could
continue to
build out why is he making tens of
millions of dollars a year
when he's primarily making money off the
labor of black men in the nba
right and so i think what happens is
anybody who's
managing that worldwide league must be
super easy right anyway anybody could be
yeah
right yes but i think what happens is
it's an element of self-preservation
so i don't think adam silver i think if
you gave him truth serum and he was
sitting here with you right now he'd say
that's an utterly ludicrous idea but i
think the problem is
people in positions of power are so
afraid that they're going to end up the
target
that they go as far left as they
possibly can because that way they can
be like
my hand what are you talking about i'm
super woke like we replaced the word
owners with governors i'm sensitive
to your feelings and that's a big
problem is there's a difference between
hearing somebody's argument and at least
contemplating it
and being sensitive to an argument right
there are lots of dumb arguments
calling an argument dumb is not
insensitive it actually honors the
argument to be discussing it
uh but i think that uh that they're like
i did a poll
i think that 95 percent of sports fans
do not think remotely that the word
owner is racist
but people like adam silver in positions
of power are afraid that the platform
that a guy like draymond green has
who wants to say by the way draymond
green said he was an
owner in his twitter bike oh right right
remember like
it's like these guys are not even able
to avoid hypocritical behavior
for a short segment of time right like
draymond green says the word owner is
offensive
and yet in his own bio he's an owner and
look
ownership is an aspirable goal
in the united states in capitalism right
you want to own your home
you want to own a business you want to
own your education like
owning something is a powerful thing for
an individual so
and then you replace it like you said
with a word that doesn't even mean the
same thing
and arguably so first of all they are
now governors of teams right
that doesn't make any sense because a
governor is primarily an elected
official
these guys bought the team and the
failure for somebody like adam silver to
be like hey
i heard that argument but here's the
truth they own the franchise
not the individuals if people don't want
to play in our league they can go
elsewhere and make a living somewhere uh
doing something else
that's a pretty good argument and i
don't he's a reasonable guy
and he's afraid to say the reasonable
thing because then he ends up at target
is the irony though that the destructive
force that you're talking about
actually transcends race because so i
got you that adam silver he's
yeah and i'm a white guy so i better you
know offer some penance here
but the simple truth is that most likely
one day even though he's doing a pretty
damn good job in terms of economics
he'll be replaced and he'll be replaced
most likely
i i would guess if i had to guess it's
probably going to be by a black woman
yeah
actually if you were just putting odds
out i think there's a good chance so but
let's just say
it's a black man or a black woman well
the second that that black man or woman
does anything that those guys don't like
they'll say that they're an uncle tom
and a seller and the rest of it so it's
like you actually have no protection
in the world of social justice no matter
you know what i mean the second they
want to use your
minority status against you i mean
everyone watching this knows that it's
like
those guys will even be treated worse
they'll be looking at adam silver going
oh those are the good old days
and and that's why you need to have
somebody who's willing to stand up and
just respond and i think the fear is in
getting engaged in that fight
but ultimately we need to be having more
battles ironically enough we need to
have
more reasonable people who are willing
to step into the fray
because i do think there is a huge i
don't think i'm almost a 1 billion
percent certain
there's a because they respond to my
show and i'm one of the only people
who's making these arguments
there's a huge silent majority out there
that thinks that these arguments are
ludicrous
and uh i think it you know kind of
translates into the democratic
presidential debates i think everybody
is so afraid of being attacked
my thing is being attack's a good thing
right like
people it means it means that you are
having an influence
and that they're afraid of the influence
that you're having uh
so you know i i don't run away from
attack i kind of enjoy you know like
what it was the old argument you know
like a
pig in the mud like enjoys being there i
kind of like being down in the muck
rolling around getting in a fight good
fight every now and then
um and i think though when it happens to
you yeah and you're just trying to do
something decent
yeah that's the thing for me that i had
to adjust because i actually don't mind
the hate now because i agree it's like
right well they're all talking about me
people are waking up in the morning and
going what did reuben do
yeah really you're doing that but but
there's a there's still a part of me
that's like
well i'm trying to be so freaking decent
i truly yeah i understand that
yeah i tried i talk about ideas all that
stuff and it's like that still is what
they're going for which really
tells it says more about them than it
says about you totally and i think the
other thing i would say for everybody
out there is these stories last 24 hours
so initially you know early on in
twitter i understand that feeling where
suddenly 100 people decide you're the
most awful human being on the planet
because of something you said that
really is pretty innocuous right i
didn't know who you were an hour before
yeah and now you're like an awful human
being
and uh and you know used to i'd look at
it and i'd be bothered by it
now you know like i just say okay like
i've got three kids at home
like let's go down to the park you know
like you know 24 hours there's going to
be something new that they decide to get
offended by
and it's not going to change the way
that i talk about my opinions
and ultimately i also don't think it's
going to have an impact on my career now
maybe i'm wrong
maybe at some point i am going to
totally get canceled but uh
in this cancel culture that we live in
because somebody decides i said
something that they don't like
but i think working on something yeah
yeah yeah yeah i i think that we've
entered the world where the
once you get and that that's where i
think you and i both are now
my audience is not suddenly going to say
i hate clay travis and completely
abandon me
right and so i think the the fear out
there is that there's not people who are
going to have your back
i feel like we've reached the point
where we have a lot of people who have
our back and
it's just basically a perpetual war yeah
god
there's so much there we could we could
do five hours yeah yeah just unpacking
and it's important because i do i sense
it especially at colleges with these
young kids
that are just afraid to get in the fight
a little bit more oh i see that all the
time it's like you're seeding a lot of
ground
people that will gladly silence you you
know yeah and that's to me the scariest
thing about our culture today is
and i wrote about this the other day and
i certainly wrote in my book there's a
difference between i disagree with you
and here's why
and i disagree with you and you
shouldn't be allowed to make the
argument that you're making
right the cancel culture to me is really
scary in our country because
there are a lot of people out there who
want to cease
the debate in general and just cancel
you out of the debate
and that's fundamentally anti-democratic
it's anti-first amendment it's
anti-american values
and the few the fact that there's not
more people standing up
to fight against that and in favor of
that like again
i think back to howard stern for
instance who's now evidently gone woke
too
right in many of the ways that he's been
right i've heard a little bit but
yeah he's started to go a little bit
woke but i think
um i think it's because he fears all the
things that he's done in the past
that if he continues in this era they'll
go back and they'll track through all
these different tapes and everything
that he said over the years
but i think that uh you know
what they found was in his early days
people wanted to silence him right
and what's wild about that is it's a big
circle because it used to be
conservative people
who were like in that position and now i
think conservatives have
realized wait a minute we need to have a
robust battlefield of ideas
and uh and the fact that you know in
that in my life
liberals could be the people on a campus
saying
i'm upset because of an idea or i'm
upset like they are in san francisco
right now because of this
old mural of george washington that's on
the wall in that school
or i'm upset because of this statue
that's out there or i'm upset because of
a word that somebody used or a phrase
or a sentence or a paragraph that
somebody wrote
it's like how sensitive have we become
as a society
it honestly is i think the most scary
thing that's going on in the country
today
yeah you know there's that great uh
moment in private parts in the howard
street ruby where
the the um executive comes out and he
says
you know the people that love you watch
you listen to you for
seven minutes a day he's like the people
that hate you listen to you for an hour
and a half
yeah and it's like yeah they listened
they hated him but they listened and now
that culture
is on social media dominating the hate
culture and i remember talking with a
politician a while back
when i was working in politics and and
we were talking about yes no votes
uh and uh you know a lot of times you no
matter who you are
what political persuasion you have
you'll stand in front of that
yes no question and you'll be like it's
a really complex
you know i don't even know what this
means right i'm a lawyer and i'm
standing there like i don't know whether
i should be yes
no they're like his like 30 percent of
people vote no no matter what
right uh like it doesn't matter what the
question could be because you always
look at those yes no ballots and it's
never
something never wins like 95 to five
right it's always 70
roughly yes 70 to 30 is a wipeout right
in a voting
booth and there is a certain segment of
the population that is titillated by
being offended by things right like
that's their thing
the problem is we have allowed those
people to
be voices that we give way too much
legitimacy to because one it's a
minority of voices
and two it's not actually reflective of
life there's that pew study recently
that came out
that said people hate political
correctness right whether you're white
black
brown asian whatever you are you hate it
and uh and yet we've allowed that
culture to predominate yeah we're
seeding it basically
eight percent a hysterical eight percent
yeah so then
it leads to the question which is what
everyone asks me and i don't know what
the answer is and i've thought about it
a lot and i can only come up with some
things that i wouldn't even want to say
but how horrible does this thing have to
get
before it implodes like what what do you
think would actually cause it
to lose its energy so i think that
first of all there are a lot of people i
think who have been
funny and smart about ridiculing you
know for instance the chicago cubs we
had the okay sign right
and the cubs are like oh my god this fan
is banned from life theo epstein is like
i was literally shivering when i was
seeing it and
i don't know about you but the vast
majority of people like when i was
growing up
if you look down when somebody did that
you got punched in the arm right
i think that is a vast majority of the
perspective
yeah so the argument that is out there
that common things which are used by
white supremacist groups somehow render
them
unusable is a so utterly absurd argument
right because i'm like well
you know white supremacists drive cars
right white supremacists
fly on airplanes white supremacists
shake hands right like
the idea that you're going to identify a
symbol with a particular group and try
to ban it
to me proves the hysteria that we're
currently living in
like we saw with nike saying oh colin
kaepernick's offended by the betsy
freaking ross flag
right and so uh we're not going to allow
that shoe to be released
and so i think reasonable people look at
this and start to recognize the hysteria
so i had a
you know somebody sent me this but i
think it's a funny question what if
white supremacists just
went all in on nike gear like flip the
script right and they're like
we're only like every event that we do
we're only going to wear nike does nike
cancel
itself does it change the name of nike
right imagine how funny that would be if
like the next
the next kkk rally you know like if
everybody at the kkk round
that's right and everybody's like a
million people stand around a year yell
at them
but what if the kkkis like had a sense
of humor and irony which they probably
don't right because they're
ideologues who are absolutists which are
always the people who are craziest right
but what if they showed up in all nike
gear and they're like
nike is now a white supremacist uh
endorsed company
we only wear nike head to toe right
would nike be like we're gonna ban like
the the the way that you follow the
logic down its
absurd path and you i think that they're
all it's almost like you got to smuggle
a little logic into their ridiculousness
right and and and that's like uh that's
like my argument uh martin luther king
was
opposed like said that uh like in he
gave
an interview uh where uh i think it was
in
ebony magazine back in the day and he
was asked a question about uh
gay rights uh basically like how do i'm
afraid my i'm gay like what should i do
he's like well it's probably a medical
condition you should go talk to a doctor
and like
if an if a political candidate gave that
answer today they would be canceled
right like particularly if they're a
democrat god forbid
so uh i was like if you immediately
respond i went to martin luther king
high school
like do we have to take martin luther
king's name off my high school do we
have to tear down the martin luther king
memorial
i think when you start to put people
like well no i mean like that was in the
1950s i'm like
yeah well george washington was around
in the 1790s right like
uh thomas jefferson was around in the in
the seventh in the uh in the 18th
century like what do you want to do
there
like in terms of analyzing it so i think
you need to flip it
on people um and make them realize oh
wait the people that we believe
are icons of our universe are actually
flawed human beings as well
and maybe we shouldn't judge every
single act they did
predicated on whatever the rules are now
but yeah that one i love like
if if white supremacists are just like
we're head to toe nike now instead of
burning it
right if you're like and then what does
nike do like he's like oh my what do we
change the name of the company
do we like uh like how do we how do we
retake our brand like
this idea that because somebody you
disagree with
likes something you have to not be
touched by it
like when i saw with the mayor pete like
he was gonna come on your program and
like have a legitimate conversation
and the same way i treat everybody
people yeah and and then people are like
oh my god if you sit down and talk to
that guy you are somehow like
you're you're canceled to us like it's
crazy right i mean like i would put
the most right-wing person like if
whoever the democrats nominate for
president i'd love to have him on my fox
sports radio show
whoever the republicans of donald trump
i'd love to have him on
when did we enter this culture where
somehow if you talk to someone
it means that you agree with everything
that they represent like
i said you know there's also this crazy
way we frame things yeah so andy know
who got attacked by it oh it's crazy
portland
who i know him and he was on the show
last week and he's a good decent guy
he's a
five foot five soft-spoken little gay
vietnamese guy and i only mentioned
those qualifiers right to use
their id you know ridiculous identity
podcasts against themselves but it's
like he's a decent guy in the way that
everyone was framing it was either that
the journalist the czech journalist
we're all saying he's either not a
journalist they talk right he's not a
journalist
or he's a fascist as if either one of
those would uh excuse violence no i
would just say compare the response to
uh the woman who got killed in
charlottesville yeah right uh by
the by the you know crazy deranged dude
who i think has got life in prison
deservedly so right
and people were like oh my god this is
what happens in trump's america
totally innocent people get attacked for
their political beliefs
and there was a mass out uproar you know
it still is impacting things i think i
saw in charlottesville where they
are no longer celebrating thomas
jefferson's birthday as part of the
fallout from that they now have um you
know another day that they've replaced
it with or whatever else
again because people are afraid i think
to have a legitimate argument ironically
enough
in a place like charlottesville which is
founded on the idea of intellectual
freedom
um and the response to that attack on uh
by
by a group that is i mean it's it's wild
right or the covington i mean the way
that they just
you go narrative first and then you
figure it out afterwards yeah like
where where are all the tweets guys
where are all the tweets about what a
racist homophobic nation
so this one doesn't work for you and i
think part of the problem is
in a large sense you can find evidence
for whatever you want
in the world or in the country on a
day-to-day basis and what we've lost the
ability to do
and i wrote about this a lot in my book
is comprehend probability
right like are there still racist in
this country certainly
are there still homophobes in this
country certainly but they represent
particularly for acts of violence a tiny
tiny percentage of the overall
population yet in the same way let's say
there are 40
000 people a year who die in car
accidents if the media decided to cover
car accident deaths in the same way that
they cover police shootings
or in the same way that they cover you
know a a mass shooting or whatever else
people would be terrified to get in
their car right they'd be like oh my god
we got another you know what's 40 000
divided by 365 i mean there are hundreds
if not thousands of people
dying on a week-to-week basis a
day-to-day basis
and yet we kind of get used to that
right but also what is it that they
ultimately want to happen to yeah i
don't know
that's what i was thinking about because
it's like if i found out that the guy
that lives across the street from me
was a homophobe yeah right meaning he
had an irrational
fear of gay right well as long as he
didn't come to my lawn and stand across
my house and lob
you know molotov cocktail yeah whatever
it's like you want to be having
irrational
fear of gay people in your own home yes
you're allowed to do it like would it be
would it be worthy of my time or
sensible for uh for a greater society
for me to you know pick up confront him
try to get him fired up you think at the
end now i accomplished all those things
now he has to move he lost his job
he's destitute his wife divorced him you
think he's gonna be like you know i kind
of like gay guys gay people
no i mean i i think that speaks to a
larger context a uh
uh handshake's always more powerful than
a fist right ultimately because
and i think you've reached the point way
long ago beyond the point of
you know diminishing returns right where
uh
if you look i wish that nobody was
racist i wish that nobody was homophobic
in this country
but i think in trying to drive it down
to
zero first of all you end up in this
strange world where
you have to define what is gay uh
homophobia and what is racism
and oftentimes you're coming around
nowadays to owner
you know the word owner right there is a
there is a more
demand for racism in this country than
there is supply which is why the wall
street journal had a big editorial
recently you mentioned jossey smallett
um there is a huge desire to use this
as an example of the larger societal
issue
and i think that's a failure of
journalism right if you think about it
journalism starts with story right
and the story will oftentimes be used to
illuminate a larger issue i'll give you
an example a lot of people are dying
from opioids
in order to draw somebody into the
opioid crisis it makes sense i think to
go talk about the impact on a family
in ohio as a larger representative for
the tens of thousands of people who
might be dying or afflicted by opioid
addiction
but that's a massive issue in the
country today which has
tangible results dead people that
otherwise wouldn't exist
because of the opioid crisis if you take
something that is not necessarily a
major issue today
let's say that jossey small it did
happen it was still a
miniscule you know number of people that
was going to be involved in this attack
and it's not necessarily representative
of the larger society
yet that's the argument that they try to
make oh this is a stand-in for something
larger
well no it's not it doesn't happen very
often at all it's a barren
much like and this is the argument i
make in my book a shark attack
right every shark attack gets news right
because ultimately we're all
terrified summer jaws season is going on
i'm sure when you go in the ocean at
some point when i do two
most influential movie ever made is jaws
because i think i might get killed by a
shark
i stood that problem in pools for the
first time yeah yeah that's right
you know statistically it's totally
improbable
yet every shark attack gets covered so
we think that it happens more frequently
than it does
i feel like we've lost you were talking
earlier about like the nightly news the
walter cronkites of the world
there aren't people saying you know this
is this is a reasonable
reaction lebron for instance said every
day my son
leaves the house i worry that he might
not come back home and everybody was
like oh it's so brave of lebron james to
say that more
young black kids are getting killed by
bees wasps and hornets
leaving the house every day than by
police if lebron had come out and said
i worry every day that when my kid
leaves the front door of his house
he's going to get killed by a bee a wasp
or a hornet people have been like
man lebron needs to chill out right like
but it's more likely or hit by a train
right like it's more likely some of this
is just the way we're wired like
certain people's brains are wired for
that type of hysteria
you may have seen this video when i was
at university of new hampshire and all
these kids are screaming at me and
yelling
and then this woman this middle-aged
woman gets up and she's screaming at me
and she goes these kids could be killed
when they walk out of here
and i don't even remember what i said to
her but what i was thinking was
what are you what planet are you yeah
these are kids at the university of new
hampshire
in the middle of nowhere there's no
violence here no one's getting killed
and yet you're an adult telling these
kids that they should be fearful they're
if anyone should have been feeling
for their life at that moment yes but
but that sort of thing it just goes to a
certain part of the brain that then just
gets fed
fed and fed i think politicians have
become astute at motivating base
audiences by fear right and i i think
certainly the left-wing has become
more uh more likely to do this but i
think
historically the right-wing has done it
as well right and
the problem is you need somebody this is
where i think obama failed as
a as a politician he is a very logical
guy whether you agree or disagree with
him i think he looks at data
and he makes arguments he should have as
some of this hysteria started
actually i think he could have made a
tremendous impact if he had come out and
said look are there bad police yes
look i wish that there were no bad
police in this country some of them
can't be trusted
but let's just walk through the
statistics you know the number one
help to entire inner city america
is police officers right look here's the
data on murders
as they pertain to over the last 30 or
40 years right
this is a trend line that's regularly
going down here's the number of police
that we employ this is a trend line
that's going up
employing more police makes people safer
it doesn't mean they're going to be
flawless they have guns on their hips
sometimes they make bad decisions when
they do they should be prosecuted in a
court of law
like anybody else who makes those
decisions and i wonder on some level
whether
obama feels bad about the hysteria
because i think the problem we had in
2016
was hillary if you go look at the
numbers of voters right
hillary didn't get the same black voters
that obama did and i think
ultimately she ran an identity politics
laden campaign
because she thought if i make it seem
like it's awful for black people in this
country today
and what donald trump will do to them is
going to be awful then they will turn up
and vote for me which will allow me to
win the election
and i think in 2020 we're going to see a
reprisal of that now
the people in the midwest were smart
enough who flipped from obama
and trump to see through that on some
level but this is an election that's
going to be decided in pennsylvania
michigan
and ohio and wisconsin i think those
four states
and so whoever the democrats nominate i
think they're going to look at the black
turnout
and say man if we got the same black
turnout that obama got we would have won
this election
how do we get it no matter who the
nominee is in 2020
we're going to try to sell fear to that
audience you think the simple
uh proof on that is that we once had
dinner with candace always yes
with far right racist yeah or whatever
the hell
they call her now uh but remember a
couple months ago when the reparations
talk started bubbling up and then
elizabeth warren said you know a
commission and then the rest of them
started saying we're going to get into
reparations
yeah i texted candace and i said i think
you've done it
i think you caused such a crack yeah
in the foundation the foundation of that
black people have to be democrats yes
that they literally now are saying what
do we got left here's cold hard catch
that's all we got left and the fact that
they're making that an issue
shows that one person i mean it's a
through line to what we're talking about
here that one person
that stakes out some brave position yes
that they really believe in
actually can cause immeasurable change
because i really do believe it is
directly
related to what she has done yeah look
you can you can criticize her and people
get angry right i defend her and blah
blah blah
well she's not perfect and i'm not
perfect and all that stuff but i truly
believe it is because of what she caused
yeah look i think the foundation of
identity politics collapsing
is maybe the most important thing that
could happen in our country
right because i think the idea that you
should be able to look at somebody and
guess who they're going to vote for
is the foundation of our politics today
right
um and uh and certainly fear if it's
used to motivate a voter
i think is often bad now look you can
criticize the other side too right
nobody's perfect i think that
republicans in general have over
emphasized the danger of terrorism right
to make people think that they're in
more danger than they are the reality
isn't maybe i'm going to get shot as
soon as i walk out
and that would certainly be an island
yeah it could be your homophobic
neighbor
who thinks i'm gay but uh the reality is
we have never been safer right and i
think about this a lot as a parent
because um you know in my city where i
live nashville tennessee
uh i try to consciously let my kids take
risks like let them get on their bike
let them ride down the street we are so
suffused i think with fear
as parents i think that kind of
translates through to our kids
who live in this incredibly anxious
world where they feel like they're in
danger and i'm like
i you know in the early 80s we were in
much more danger
than our kids are today in the 60s let
me climb trees in front of the house i'd
be 100 feet in the air
my mom would come in for lunch i'm like
i'm i don't know how i'm going to get
down but i always got down yeah
i think about it now you know like i
rode the school bus uh in fourth and
fifth grade got home
got off the school bus walked all the
way you know down the street up to my
house
a totally empty house unlocked the door
went inside stayed there for a couple of
hours by myself
right i mean and i was 10. right i mean
and my i've got an 11 year old now
and if we go to the swimming pool in our
neighborhood across the street
my wife's like oh my god do you think we
can leave him here for a little while
i'm like he's
he's going to be in sixth grade right
like i mean um but i think it's just
you know we have sort of built this
cocoon of protectiveness protectiveness
and that
can be good but not when it's motivated
by fear and i think that that's that's
that's that's that's what's over
sidebar to this yeah nashville so i i
performed you might have seen yeah
in the in the green room bathroom over
there is me at the ryman which is
incredible grand old opera was one of
the most memorable nights but what is
going on in nashville
that everybody is so freaking happy i
have never seen a happier
nicer maybe maybe there's something
going on first of all
whichever came around don't move don't
move here we got enough of you you know
we're i'm born and raised in nashville i
think the culture of the place
i've never seen a group but every single
person that i walk by on the street
offered to bring me to their house for
dinner and check me out to eat can i buy
you a drink
yeah what can i do for you you want
literally people you want can i buy you
a new jacket yeah yeah
it was unbelievable it's a super nice
community
um that i think uh i don't know what
exactly it is i think one you get the
southern element
um two i think the economy has been
booming so people do feel really good
about you know their overall status in
life
um three i think the entertainment
culture we kind of have a lot of the la
vibe of creativity and just freedom and
individual
uh you know sort of uh uh choices that
that i think is so important in life
and uh but without a lot of the
negativity associated with it i don't
know whether it's because
musicians don't have to be beautiful
like a lot of actors and actresses do
uh but it's uh you know uh i i really
love it i mean
we don't want to move i mean i'm born
and raised i think it was a great
culture for me to grow up in and i think
it's an even better one for my kids it's
funny to me that you made a point of
looking at the camera
i just i like that's a movie well
everybody else is out there saying like
it's an awesome place
i'm like no we're full right like you
know how uh i feel like as a parent kind
of
my kids are at perfect ages they're 11 8
and 4. and i would be
you know they're potty trained they'd
still like to spend time with us like we
uh we can enjoy them as a family
i'd be fine hitting pause right now in
my life and having them hang out here
for a little while
because i know you know my father-in-law
was telling me this he's like
you're in a good spot right now the kids
still have lots of problems
but they're almost all little problems
as your kids get older they have fewer
problems but they become a lot bigger
right and that makes sense right as you
think about it from a parent perspective
but the city of nashville like you used
to be able to get everywhere in 10 or 15
minutes
now the traffic there's so many people
moved in yeah and that can bring a lot
of good things and it's been a good
audience growth a lot of college
educated lots of bars restaurants
awesome entertainment scene uh but we're
full
yeah you need to move to another city
it's funny because every town that i
visited last year whenever i saw
something really great happening in that
town like salt lake city i was like yeah
people are phenomenal yeah it's clean
it's nice
and i did stand up there and i said
something about how great it is there
and literally people were coming up to
me after going please don't tell anybody
california don't you guys are leaving
and ruining everything it's funny when i
started we're big on that when i started
my career because i did local sports
talk radio in nashville
uh as my profile kind of grew i would
talk a lot about how awesome nashville
was and this is you know over the last
15 years
and about two or three years ago i just
stopped talking about how awesome the
city is right because i'm like
i think i've had too much of an
influence on some way like you know
but people are just scrolling through
and they're thinking about where to move
i think it also helps by the way
we've got no state income tax so if
you're out in california 13
state income tax let's say you make a
million dollars a year and you're an
entertainer
that's a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars a year boom
that you have in your pocket in
nashville that you didn't necessarily
have if you lived in california or new
york
it's it's i sometimes wonder why we
don't have more of our fox sports
studios out there because i'm
you know doing the show to finish the
season here um and uh
and you know it's great to be able to do
it out in nashville yeah all right let's
back up
yes to 20 minutes ago i want to talk
about some of the gender stuff yeah
related sports because you mentioned the
women's soccer team now it's great
they won okay fantastic everybody's
happy but yes
there are economic elements to this that
less people happen to watch those things
it's just reality it just is nobody's
saying they're not worthy nobody's
saying it shouldn't be on tv nobody's
saying they shouldn't be able to play
uh but this constant then need where it
became about their victimhood
as they were winning yes as you're
winning but the whole idea is a we're
you know we're not going to respect the
flag and whatever they can just they can
do whatever they want but then also just
we don't get the tv time
and it's like all these things like this
is such a such a misguided
let's take a step back i said on my show
and again this is something that's
reasonable
that some people consider to be
controversial so you'll enjoy this i
said if you look at the women's world
cup
you can almost pick every winner solely
by determining which country has better
women's rights
it's a fascinating way just look at the
bracket you look at every women's world
cup game that was played
almost every game without fail the
winner was the country that provides
more rights to women
so it's fascinating to think about we
are as a country so wealthy
and so successful that we not only
embrace men's sports which many
countries do
we also have so many parents out there
who will spend
thousands of dollars a year for their
women
to be able to their little girls to be
able to play soccer and grow up
potentially to be u.s women's
soccer team member look at our the girls
that were on the team the women that won
the title this year they used to be
little girls who grew up in pretty
advantage backgrounds right
because by and large soccer in america
unlike soccer and the rest of the world
is a sport that elites play right uh
suburban sport
especially for women and so the argument
that i made is
if anything megan repino instead of
saying i'm not going to the effing white
house and she said [ __ ] i should i'm
not going to the [ __ ] white house
which i think sounds different
she should have in my opinion said you
know
i have this opportunity as a captain of
the women's team to make that argument
that i just made
if we can be a shining light to the rest
of the world
this is what happens when you give
little girls the freedom to pursue
things that interest them
they grow up into women who can dominate
and so there's a lot of talk about the
women versus the men
right but the reason why our men
struggle in soccer is because the rest
of the world identifies great male
athletes and they develop them
in iran last year was the first time
they let women
watch soccer in their country they
require women to play in
pants they require women to wear the
hijab where you can just see their eyes
on the football on the soccer field um
think about that is it a surprise that
u.s women would dominate a country
that doesn't let women wear shorts or
attend soccer matches
is it a surprise that we would dominate
saudi arabia where they just started
letting women drive cars
you know so our women's success to me is
actually
a reflection of the ideals that they
should be trying to shed
and shine a bright light on for the rest
of the world having said that
the rest of the world doesn't care about
women's soccer like the united states
does
so pure economics when you look at this
and again this is pure rational
economics
the men's world cup produced most
recently the most recent numbers i saw
4 billion dollars of revenue right b b
the women's world cup in i think it was
the most recent by 2015
produced 73 million in revenue
associated with it now that's continuing
to grow
but the men in america actually made a
smaller percentage of the fifa revenue i
think it was nine percent
than the women did they got 13 so take a
step back from everybody i think in
general is in favor of equality right i
mean there are very few people who are
like oh i think because of your sex you
should have less rights than someone
else
again tiny tiny percentage so to me when
you look at this
it's just a function of economics i wish
i made the money that howard stern makes
right we do the same thing we talk on
the radio every morning why do i make
less money than he does
because my audience is smaller and the
reason why the u.s women and the revenue
that my audience produces is lower right
it's basic economics so i understand the
argument of oh the u.s women deserve
more certainly i hope they get as much
as they possibly can i'm a capitalist i
want every individual to make as much
money as they can
but the money's not there right and so
the reason why the money's not there is
because the world not the united states
the world doesn't value women's soccer
as much as they do men's soccer you
think trump every time
rapino or one of these athletes says
they're not going to go to the white
house or
[ __ ] the white house or whatever you
think he's just like hallelujah
hallelujah this is just going to make me
more popular because
to me it's the ultimate virtue signal
like yeah why not instead of saying that
why not you honored your country you you
won for your country why not show up at
the white house and then
do what an adult might do which when he
walks by and shakes all your hands say
mr president i'd love to have five
minutes with you
ask for a meeting which he's shown that
he's willing to do
like this is what's so crazy this about
me and and i i i don't know about you
but this is what really bothers me in
general about the discussion about the
white house visit
i would go to the white house if i were
invited by
bill clinton barack obama george w bush
george bush
donald trump the idea that that is
somehow an endorsement of whoever is
president
is crazy to me to me it's just a respect
for the office itself
and the location and that's why when
megan rapino said the [ __ ] white
house
it's like the white house is a symbol
that represents everything that's good
and great about america including
the rights that allowed you to become
such a dominant women's soccer player to
begin with
and by the way and you know this better
than me i believe on election to enter
the white house for the first term
trump is the most gay lgbt friendly
president
ever literally well first off he was
basically pro-gay marriage yes remember
barack obama again was not
in 2008 he was on stage with a freaking
gay pride flag
yeah before the election peter thiel at
the at the spoke at the artist
a proud gay man gets a standing ovation
nobody even knew what to do
so yeah it's all it's all just bananas
and so that is what is so problematic
and disappointing to me in many respects
is
what does she actually disagree with and
that's the question where i think the
sports media often
does not go the next level they they
cover the surface
level virtue signaling right okay
the next question for megan rupino is
okay what do you specifically disagree
with donald trump that he has done
not just like a mean tweet that he sent
or something like a a tangible
a decision and why would you not take
the opportunity to sit with the most
powerful man in the world
and talk to him about it because if
anything trump has proven
to actually listen to some of these
arguments right like is the catch 22
though for not for you because you can
do what you want and you can control the
content you're creating
but for espn i get it they can do it at
sort of the base level but then the more
they were to do of that it's the more
that a guy like me who
i'm not a i don't really care about
soccer yeah that is i was telling you
right before we started i think that i
just now flick through like i see yeah
and it's so i used to you know even five
years ago i would always stop on
what's going on and now it's just like
like i know that whatever is on right
now i could not care less about it i
think what would happen is the athletes
would get exposed
by and large because you would find out
espn
right but that what you would find out
is there's no depth to their actual
political opinions because they're doing
other things full-time
right like i think if lebron james who
is obviously
super woke right now because i think he
gets positive feedback on social media
and everything else
if you set him down and said okay lebron
like you called the president a bum
explain why specifically you think the
president is a bum and
what you would change differently if you
were in the white house
you would realize wait a minute like he
would just him and haw and he wouldn't
have any answers like you or i or
any number of people and maybe that
athlete does have some depth to them
and that's why i've always offered you
know like i offered colin kaepernick i
offered lebron james i offer
megan repino like come on my show and
actually make your arguments that you
believe you have this platform to make
we never see that happen right we hear
people say oh i've got to use my
platform
well how are you using your platform to
advocate for like an
actual change or some sort of detail i
never see that actually happen
it's interesting your point about how
trump would be happy to take these
meetings
because you're right he does take these
meetings all the time
especially with famous people when it's
good television ops right like
trump sitting with megan rupino on the
other side of the desk in the oval
office
he'd let all the meat like he did with
kanye and kim kardashian right like
trump is a very cognizant of the amount
of attention that he can get and the
more famous a person he meets with the
more attention he's going to get
particularly in the world of sports
whether it's jim brown whether it's
he just announced that the logo jerry
west he's bringing in tiger woods
trump's a sports fan right and i think
he enjoys tom brady obviously that all
of the talk about the brady and
belichick relationship and everything
else
um and so i think he enjoys being able
to interact with him as president
and yeah i think he would always have
that meeting if you wanted to have that
meeting
do you get any feedback from women in
the sports broadcasting
world that are sick of the wokeness when
it comes to all the gender
stuff yeah that's got that to me is the
most obvious one like we can
argue about some of the the racial stuff
yeah and numbers and things like that
but this one now where we're seeing
you know trans wrestlers uh beating the
crap
basically out of uh you know genetically
female women and it's like
now the feminists are well or that yeah
i think that what are we doing
yeah i think that's you talked about how
do you blow it up i think you have to
follow the logical
collapse of the argument right um and to
me
choosing your gender is it's wild to me
that we're okay
with choosing your gender but choosing
your race is wildly offensive
right like so rachel dolezal is a like
is like a social pariah yeah but if
rachel dolezal
was a woman who decided to be a man we
would all have to respect that decision
and my thing is
it seems easier to choose to align
yourself with a racial group
than it does to change your gender right
but the next step from the world
yeah yeah can you imagine that coming
out today that would be amazing
um but to me the next step that you take
that is uh that is that is fascinating
here is
caitlyn jenner is a great example espn
gives caitlyn jenner and espy
what would have happened if in the
1970s when caitlyn jenner is dominating
uh bruce jenner is dominating in the
olympics
he had then decided i'm going to become
a woman and i'm going to come back and
i'm going to
you know compete against all the women
he would have dominated even more right
like
this is the greatest athlete in the
world as a man
if he flips over and becomes a woman
he's going to dominate even more
so this idea that you can choose your
gender
and that you should then be allowed to
compete as that gender it's like
they made a joke movie about this do you
remember like juwana man
yeah back in the day but but that is
going to that's the logical fallacy of
the art i cannot wait till
some 42 year old wash up washed up nba
guy
who played like seven seasons scored
three points a game
becomes the the best player in the wnba
wnba
and you guys are gonna have to take it
yeah look i mean
and i think that's honestly what you
need to have happen in order for the
logical fallacy of the argument
to fall apart right like um and i i
think that's
ultimately what spells the end of woken
in the world of sports is what you're
just talking about
they're gonna be a lot of dads and moms
who've watched their daughters
train their entire life to be able to
win the sprint state championship
and then there suddenly is a 17 year old
who
is a male that has decided to identify
as female
and wins the competition by 20 yards
right because this is again men are
better athletes than women like
i've got people right now my twitter
mentions talking about the u.s women in
the u.s men debate
and they're like oh if the u.s women
played the men they'd win
and i'm like you the the u.s women
lost to a 15 and under boys
uh all-star team from dallas right like
men are better at all sports than women
are that's not sexist
that's biology right so therefore men
who are bigger stronger and faster than
women
who suddenly decide to identify as women
are going to be better and even if they
get
all the complicated hormone stuff like
you're still built
physically in a way that most women are
not right like you're still you've got
all the height advantages of
testosterone all the shoulder
you know strength everything else it's
uh it's just
it's not it's not offensive to say that
yeah when a woman dunks in the wnba
which is only happened a handful of
times yeah it's like a miracle
yes every nba player junk i'm pretty
sure john stockton dunked once
well it was like and this is again in my
book republicans by sneakers too
john mcenroe got criticized for saying
serena williams be like the 700th best
men's player in the world
i talked to a bunch of men's tennis
players pros
and they're like she couldn't make a
men's college tennis team
doesn't mean she's not an outstanding
women's tennis player
but her talent doesn't translate into
the arena
with men and that doesn't mean that
women are inferior to men in life
right it means that athletically men are
superior to women well you saw the way
they were going after martina
navratilova oh yeah
when she wrote that piece and that
speaks to i think the the danger of
actually interjecting yourself into the
conversation
because martinez ratalova could have
just set out of it i think she wrote an
op-ed piece for a british newspaper yeah
uh i remember there was one
season right maybe the first or second
season of the wnba you remember cynthia
cooper who was on the houston comet
and she was like running circles around
everything she had great handle she had
all these sick moves
and i remember watching her and i was
like could this girl possibly make it in
the nba and in my mind i thought
that maybe she could yeah but that's
just crazy ludicrous it's just
crazy it's it's like the argument and
this goes into title
ix that i've always found would be
fascinating from a legal perspective you
talk about
extending the logical uh the logical
fallacy of the argument
football is not a men's sport like if
you really think about it
every scholarship that you get in
college to play football is open to
women like softball is a women's sport
baseball is a men's sport men's
basketball men's sport
men's uh you know basketball i mean
women's basketball women's
right they're defined by their gender
football is open to everyone
if tom if bill belichick could find
a you know five foot four woman who
could be the takeover or six foot four
woman or whatever it is for tom brady
he would sign that person to play in the
nfl and so would every college coach
those women don't exist so is that the
sickest twist to this whole thing that
yeah that
sports really because of rules yes is
the great equalizer
one billion yeah the ultimate
meritocracy
you know i think i maybe told you this
last time you were here but uh sue bird
went to the same high school
she was younger than me but every now
and again she would come out to the
courts where i was right and she'd run
circles around everybody she was awesome
i have no problem saying that she was
freaking awesome yes and
it's like that doesn't mean she's gonna
go to the nba
right but we can acknowledge that within
the the skill set playing
against all of us yeah she freaking
killed us to me it's like uh
looking at the uh the scatter plot or
the bell curve right like
uh most people are somewhere in the the
range of the top right and then there's
outliers
if you put male and female athletic
ability on that same chart
it doesn't mean that some women are not
substantially better even than most men
when it comes to athleticism
but when you look at the extremes which
are the people who end up making a
living
the men athletically are on a totally
different stratosphere than the most
athletic women
so when you say sue bird's a great
example sue bird can be a lot better
than most men at basketball and nowhere
near
the extreme of the most talented men's
basketball players
all right let's uh we only got a couple
minutes left so let's just hit a couple
of things so
there's also been a little through line
here that sort of as
people like you are doing their own
thing out of the institutions and as the
institutions are crumbling
i've come to the belief that sort of the
platforms
that all of this is going to crumble
that none of these things are
sustainable
and it'll be on creators and innovators
to figure out how to reach their
communities um
do you kind of view the future of the
internet that way because we're also in
the middle of that game right now which
is just
what is all of this going to become yeah
i think a lot about that because what am
i ultimately in the business of
words right i produce that's why
the money that i've made i've tended to
roll into buildings right because
everything that i do is so ephemeral
but i think we're in an era when and i
don't know when it's going to be i think
it's going to happen soon
you will get into your car which you may
not be driving at all but would be
transporting you somewhere
and you will hopefully say play me the
most recent clay travis
right and and boom it's ready to go now
podcasts kind of have that
but i think that all audio is going to
converge right i think radio
i think podcast i think uh you know
shows like this which can exist in both
audio and video format
everything converges and it becomes an
opportunity
to distribute your content in a way
where there's almost no top down
right everything sort of becomes bottom
up and what can eventually happen is
bottom up can become massive and i think
the ability of
companies to create stars is going to be
diminished and almost everything is
going to be rising from a bottom up
and then big companies will say oh i see
this person they're successful
and they'll try to attach to them but i
think all the time about for instance on
television
i think you'll come in and you'll sit
down and you will click on the latest
app
uploads from you know maybe it'll be
people like you and me all coming
together and like we'll have our own
brand and it'll be
under this brand umbrella right you can
go kind of check because
you know if people like you they might
like me and you kind of get a affinity
that way
everything is so competitive and to me
reed hastings has said it so brilliantly
our competition's not hbo it's sleep and
i think we're all competing against
sleep
i think there's so many you know i was
talking about this with a buddy the
other day
sports used to be in the summer i'd sit
around and watch the braves on tbs
i'd watch the uh the uh the cubs on wgn
whatever other game because everything
else was a rerun on television
in the summer right nowadays i think
baseball struggles because
stranger things three's coming out right
like my kids watching stranger things
right now
um my oldest is my two younger be
terrified i think if they got to watch
it
so we're all competing everywhere
simultaneously i think the amount of
audience will diminish but i think the
intensity of that audience will grow
such that people really really love the
things that they love yeah it's
interesting how when you're in these
things even though we're in sort of
different worlds that obviously have a
lot of overlap
that you start thinking about the same
oh yeah because i've been getting offers
left and right and what i
keep coming back to is for the first
time now just because of the craziness
with youtube and everything else
i'll consider distribution offers just i
just want my stuff to get out there i
don't care whether right that you hopped
in your automatic car
and you can just say play rubric for it
or it's some other way
but that appeals to me rather than uh
the reverse of the top-down thing
yeah i don't want to be associated with
these big things that will ultimately
one day
come and get me so it's it's interesting
how we all sort of end up hovering
around the same ideas
yeah and look i mean the reason why i
love doing your show is i do think
there's cross-pollination right i think
people like we're going to
have you on my podcast i think some
people will hear you on my show and
they'll be like i never knew that guy
existed
oh i like him right and so i think it's
it's going to be incumbent upon creators
to find
other creators that they like and sort
of
allow those two audiences to intermingle
in some way
to create bigger audiences for people of
like minds
let's just wrap with one other thing we
talked about it right before we started
um
just the way money is completely out of
control yeah with all these leagues you
who's the guy that just signed that
crazy deal said denny green and this guy
he's won a couple of championships good
three-point shooter decent player
i don't think he's ever maybe made an
older lakers game 30 million dollars 30
million
15 15 million that these numbers are
getting so out of control
that at some point people are going to
go to these games i mean i haven't been
to i didn't go to one nba game last
season for the first time in my life
right i was just more because i was busy
but it's like at some point these things
will just price themselves out and
everyone's just going to be like i'm not
buying these 80
jerseys anymore i'm not buying 12 sodas
yeah
i think what athletes are gonna have to
recognize is who pays their salary
and i think this is i think an important
lesson for anybody
employed by anyone who pays your salary
where does the money come from
right following that thread to knowing
how you get paid
i think a lot of athletes have become
comfortable alienating the fan bases
that define
their paychecks because they don't see
that direct connection right because the
television contracts are signed for 10
years
because their contracts are guaranteed
for multiple years
but ultimately it's the fan pulling
money out of his or her pocket
that is justifying what you are allowed
to make
and i think whether it's colin
kaepernick whether it's lebron james
alienating fans megan repino for any
reason
is just bad business right and that's
kind of the essence of my argument
is that michael jordan had it right when
he was asked how come you don't get
intensely political because republicans
buy sneakers too
he's not in the business of needing for
everybody to know what he thinks about
politics from one day to the next um and
i think as
as athletes are trying to turn into
uh repositories for political ideas good
you know left right and different
whatever they are
it's bad for their brands and it's bad
for the leagues overall all right
follow clay travis's brand at clay
travis on the twitter